Scientists have used EEG machines to record our brain waves while we sleep, and
while we're awake. When we're awake, our electrical brain activity is called
beta waves. However, when we're relaxed, our brain activity slows to alpha
waves. As you can see here, this is when we become drowsy, and when we first
fall asleep we don't go into rapid eye movement sleep but we go down to stage
one. And during stage one our brain waves are theta waves. So if you were
looking at a brainwave activity, you would know that somebody fell asleep
because they moved from alpha waves to theta waves. In stage one we can be
easily aroused by outside stimuli such as a phone ringing or someone walking
around or so on. After about seven minutes or so. We're going to move from
stage one to stage two. Now during stage two, which is also a type of theta
wave, we're going to see two interesting things in our electrical brain
activity. First, as you see here this is a sleep spindle. It's a sudden burst
of electrical activity in the brain waves. And here, we see a K complex which
is a single but large, high voltage spike in brain activity. Both of these
things last about a second or two. It has been proposed by some researchers
that these help us to disconnect from the outside world. After about 15 minutes
in stage two, we move on to stage three sleep. Which consists of theta waves
again, but also delta waves which are the slowest and strongest waves in our
sleep cycle. So stage three consists of some theta waves and some delta waves.
And in stage four we experience all delta waves, and this again is our deepest
stage of sleep. Now, remember, once we hit stage four, we go back up in reverse
order. So we go from stage four to three to two to one and then REM sleep. Now,
it's interesting to note that during REM sleep, we actually lose muscle tone.
This may actually help to prevent us from acting out some of our dreams. Now,
perhaps you've had a dream where you were running from someone. It would be
hazardous if our brain actually allowed us to engage in these activities.